Hi everyone,
just a quick update on some of the significant changes
which are due to take place of spring 2024.
One of those changes
is that healthcare and social workers
will no longer be able to bring their UM
dependence. Secondly,
the minimum salary for skilled workers
is due to increase from 26,200 to 38,700.
And another big hit that migration will take
is that family visa
and the minimum financial requirement
will be going up from 18,600 to 38,700.
So it might be a good time now to start considering
if you were looking to make an application
under the immigration rules
to start thinking about it
before these changes are due to take place. Thank you!